Traductor: Lucas Seoane
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Buenas tardes.
Somos el grupo de cantadoras Bojayá,
Voces de Resistencia.
Nosotras hemos venido haciendo un trabajo
en nuestra comunidad,
los alabados son ancestrales.
En los años 90,
la violencia en nuestra comunidad
estaba demasiado pesada.
Había una persona,
quien era que nos llevaba la alimentación,
porque no nos dejaban salir sino.
Tenía por familia comprar 20 000 pesos
que no satisfacía ni para el día.
Entonces, en el 97,
mataron a esa persona.
Entonces nosotras nos pusimos
a hacer composiciones en honor a él.
Se vino el problema, grandísimo, del 2002.
Que, se vino la violencia
y acabó que asesinó a 79 personas.
No sabíamos que hacer.
Entonces nos reunimos, un grupo
de personas hombres y mujeres,
y dijimos: Bueno, pongámonos a hacer
composiciones alusivas a la violencia.
Porque parece que el Estado colombiano
mira que acá en el rincón del Chocó,
hay personas que merecemos su vida.
Y al ver que nos oigan
por todos los medios,
Y que nos han estado
invitando a estos eventos.
Entonces les vamos a cantar
un primer Alabao que es los que
usamos tradicionales para fúnebre.
(Cantando)
Por el rostro y por la sangre,
que Jesús ha derramado.
Camina la Virgen pura,
en busca de su hijo amado.
Y en busca de su hijo amado.
Y en busca de su hijo amado,
y en busca de su hijo amado.
Por el rostro y por la sangre,
que Jesús ha derramado.
Camina la Virgen pura,
en busca de su hijo amado.
Y en busca de su hijo amado.
Y en busca de su hijo amado,
y en busca de su hijo amado.
Por las tres leguas que anduve,
una mujer me he encontrado.
Decirme buena mujer,
si a Jesús me lo has hallado.
Si a Jesús me lo has hallado.
Si a Jesús me lo has hallado,
si a Jesús me lo has hallado.
Por el rostro y por la sangre,
que Jesús ha derramado.
Camina la Virgen pura,
en busca de su hijo amado.
Y en busca de su hijo amado.
Y en busca de su hijo amado,
y en busca de su hijo amado.
Si lo ha encontrado señora,
y en la cruz crucificado.
Una corona de espinas,
y una llaga en el costado.
Y una llaga en el costado.
Y una llaga en el costado,
y una llaga en el costado.
Por el rostro y por la sangre,
que Jesús ha derramado.
Camina la Virgen pura,
en busca de su hijo amado.
Y en busca de su hijo amado.
Y en busca de su hijo amado,
y en busca de su hijo amado.
Ya Jesucristo murió,
y allá lo llevan cantando.
Donde lo van a enterrar,
allá en el Monte Calvario.
Y allá en el Monte Calvario.
Y allá en el Monte Calvario,
y allá en el Monte Calvario.
Por el rostro y por la sangre,
que Jesús ha derramado.
Camina la Virgen pura,
y en busca de su hijo amado.
Y en busca de su hijo amado.
Y en busca de su hijo amado,
y en busca de su hijo amado.
(Fin de la canción)
(Aplausos)
Bueno.
Ahora, les vamos a cantar
Alusivo a la violencia.
(Cantando)
Nosotras somos víctimas
del conflicto en Bojayá.
Vamos a presentar el grupo,
ya no resistimos más.
Respeten nuestros derechos,
para que no vuelva a pasar.
Nosotros los campesinos
sí luchamos por la paz.
Estamos en Bojayá
compartiendo resistencia.
Y estamos en Bojayá
Con todos nuestros vecinos
no queremos más violencia.
Respeten nuestros derechos
para que no vuelva a pasar.
Nosotros los campesinos
sí luchamos por la paz.
Los ancestros fallecidos
nos dieron nuestro talento.
Ya se fueron para siempre
y seguimos produciendo.
Respeten nuestros derechos
para que no vuelva a pasar.
Nosotros los campesinos
sí luchamos por la paz.
Con esta nos despedimos,
pongamos mucha atención.
Somos el grupo de Alabao
y queremos indemnización.
Respeten nuestros derechos
para que no vuelva a pasar.
Nosotros los campesinos
sí luchamos por la paz.
(Fin de la canción)
(Aplausos)
Ahorita vamos a cantar
un canto que nosotros le decimos
Arrullo o Chigüalos.
Que es lo que se le canta a los niños
cuando fallecen.
Y dice:
(Cantando)
Y al pasar por el puente de la victoria,
de la victoria.
Ay por besar la madrina,
bese la novia y andando.
Que me voy navegando.
¿Para dónde?
Para la casa del conde.
¿Y a qué?
Y eso sí yo no sé.
¿Pastores?
Que me muero de amores
Ay de mí
Los enemigos
Mi madre me ha dicho
que no me case con hombres blancos
Ay porque parece
la vara del campanario y andando.
Que me voy navegando.
¿Ay para dónde?
Para la casa del conde.
¿Ay y a qué?
Y eso sí yo no sé.
Ay si digo.
Que me llamo Rodrigo.
Ay pastores.
Que me muero de amores.
Ay de mí.
Los enemigos.
Mi mamá me ha dicho que no me case
con hombres gordos-
Ay porque todas las noches
y haceme todo, y haceme todo y andando.
Que me voy navegando.
¿Y a dónde?
A la casa del conde.
¿Y a qué?
Y eso sí yo no sé.
Pastores.
Que me muero de amores.
Y ay de mí.
Los enemigos.
Mi mamá me ha dicho que no me case
con hombres viejos.
Porque todas las noches
darme consejos y andando.
Que me voy navegando.
¿Para dónde?
A la casa del conde.
¿Y a qué?
Eso sí yo no sé.
Si digo.
Yo me llamo Rodrigo.
Pastores.
Que me muero de amores.
Y ay de mí.
Los enemigos.
Mi mamá me ha dicho que no me case
con hombres flacos.
Porque todas las noches jala tabaco.
Y andando.
Yo me voy navegando.
¿Para dónde?
A la casa del conde.
¿Y a qué?
Eso sí yo no sé.
Ay si digo.
Que me llamo Rodrigo.
Pastores.
Que me muero de amores.
Y ay de mí.
Los enemigos.
Cuando voy por la calle
voy serenita, voy serenita.
Ay para que diga la gente
que soy bonita y andando.
Yo me voy navegando.
¿Para dónde?
Para la casa del conde.
¿Y a qué?
Eso sí yo no sé.
Ay si digo.
Que me llamo Rodrigo.
Pastores.
Que me muero de amores.
Y ay de mí.
Los enemigos.
La mujer junto a su hombre
huye al peligro, huye al peligro.
Ay como flores que caen
junto al camino y andando.
Yo me voy navegando.
¿Para dónde?
A la casa del conde.
¿Y a qué?
Eso sí yo no sé.
Ay si digo.
Yo me llamo Rodrigo.
Ay pastores.
Que me muero de amores.
Y ay de mí.
Los enemigos.
Ay de mí.
(Fin de la canción)
Bueno, muchas gracias.
Y esperamos que esto sea
un cambio para este país.
(Aplausos)